what's up guys this is dave klein
filling in for persia who's off petting
penguins right now
and welcome to the game pass show where
we'll let you know what's new
what's leaving and what you need to play
right now on game pass
make sure to leave a like subscribe and
let's get right into it
coming to game pass soon we've got
dragon quest builder 2
tropico 6
ufc 4
blood roots
farming simulator 19
[Music]
and the medium
sadly with games coming that means that
some games are also leaving
although fortunately not too many this
time around
ea sports ufc ea sports ufc 2
endless space 2 downwell and cross code
downwell is one that i'm personally a
big fan of and a quick pick up and play
type of game
so i highly recommend checking it out
before it's too late
with all the games on game pass it can
be a little daunting finding the right
one to play
so here's what i'm playing right now and
my pick of the week
i have been playing a hollow knight now
i first played hollow knight around when
it first came out in 2017
and fortunately it is on xbox game pass
and if you haven't played it you
absolutely need to
this is seriously one of the best
metroidvania style games i have ever
played up there with castlevania
symphony of the night
and super metroid while there's still
that exploration
in the style of you get a new ability
eventually and that allows you to
explore more of the map the difference
with hollow knight is that the combat is
super important this time around and
some of the bosses are
seriously hard you'll have to memorize
patterns you'll have to make sure that
you're dodging at the right times and
you'll have to equip the right equipment
to make sure that you're the best
prepared for these battles in a way it
honestly kind of reminds me of the mega
man series with how tight it is and that
whole
boss pattern memorization and as part of
what i love so much about the game as
mega man is another one of my favorite
series of games
which used to be on game pass and sadly
legacy collection currently isn't come
on then
get it back it needs to come back
i highly recommend it i just finished
replaying the path of pain
which is name that for a reason uh this
game gets
hard it gets really challenging if you
play some of the post game stuff
uh to get some of the secrets and secret
endings but i like that challenge
and it is definitely for me and i think
if you haven't played it you
definitely definitely need to check it
out as for my pick of the week
i have to go with down well because it's
leaving but the nice thing about down
well is as i kind of mentioned earlier
the game is really good for a pickup and
play style of game and since it's
leaving in about a week
that gives you time to pick it up play
it and you're not gonna miss too much
in a week this is the time to just play
it slam out a few sessions
and enjoy for what it is it's a fun and
addictive roguelite game with a really
simple premise
that being that you jump into a well
you're falling down
and you have gun boots so that means
you're going to try to bounce off of
various enemies they get combos which
allows you to
buy new things unlock better abilities
and also upgrade your character a little
bit as you try to work your way down to
the bottom of the well
now there are different gameplay modes
that can make it easier harder that you
can also unlock but really
it's not a long game which is why this
is such a perfect game for right now
with not too much time to play it but
it's still a good game
that is worth playing that does it for
this edition of the game pass show
make sure to hit me up and let me know
about your sweet sweet joy
or pain of playing hollow knight and
make sure to tune in again in a few
weeks for another edition of the game
pass show as we'll have all new updates
for you
and i'll see you guys next time later
[Music]
guys
you